Kylie Jenner seems to be dreading her  upcoming birthday  the reality star turns 19 on August 10  remember when she had a mini meltdown  earlier this month over her first silver  strand because my first gray hair oh my  god take it out take it again smart  well now Kylie has posted one of her  go-to mirror selfies in her pajamas to  Instagram she captioned the pic I'll be  19 in two weeks then added a sad face  emoji again Kylie is keeping her mind  off the aging process by focusing on her  business though she's been surprising  her loyal customers with early releases  of her new line of Kylie cosmetics and  she has more products on the way ahead  of her bday  you